[Musica]
ben trovati in questo mio intervento io
vorrei concentrarmi soprattutto
sull'istruzione su come questa possa
essere un'arma potentissima capace di
cambiare le cose e soprattutto a livello
globale dove ad alcune ragazze ad alcune
bambine e ancora negata possa davvero
rivelarsi un'arma efficace anche per la
loro vita futura e per la loro economia
perché io di questo mi occupo parto
dall'afghanistan dove c'è una donna
credo la più coraggiosa che io abbia mai
conosciuto il suo nome è fauzy a kofi ed
è stata la prima donna vicepresidente
del parlamento afghano suo marito è
stato ucciso dai talebani
e il ricordo benissimo un pomeriggio
bevendo tè a casa sua è un pomeriggio
l'altro nel quale entrò sua figlia che
si chiama sherazad e io ho pensato
proprio questa bambina a inviso vice
rosada il viso che mi immaginavo
corrispondesse a quel nome tanto bello
tanto altisonante una bambina che
speriamo stia proseguendo nei suoi studi
perché la vita della mamma
fauzy a coffee è stata contrassegnata da
tante tragedie e le hanno ucciso il
marito lei vive sotto scorta tuttora e
adesso sta cercando di ottenere
un accordo molto importante in
afghanistan proprio con alcuni
estremisti nulla io credo che lei sia
stata per me fonte di esempio è fonte di
come andare a scuola istruirsi avere il
sogno di entrare nel parlamento di un
paese dove è all'ordine del giorno
il fatto che la donna sia un oggetto
dove la norma e che tirassero l'acido
addosso pur di non farti andare a scuola
e sapete quante ragazzi ho intervistato
completamente bruciati o completamente
segnate da questa grandissima piaga
eppure col coraggio di andare a scuola
fauzy ha in qualche modo ha cambiato la
sua vita
perché è vero che vive sotto scorta
e vero che dalla morte del marito lei ha
avuto solo problemi pur perseguendo e
facendo il suo mestiere ma è anche vero
che per lei un grande esempio per le sue
due bambine è anche vero che lei
sicuramente darà un ritmo diverso al
futuro perché grazie a persone come lei
che le cose in quel paese potranno
migliorare ed ecco un primo esempio in
un teatro difficilissimo quello
dell'afghanistan di come l'istruzione
possa davvero cambiare le cose
il secondo sempre in afghanistan non
siamo più a kabul
siamo a herat quindi nella parte che
confina con l'iran per intenderci una
città bellissima dove c'è la moschea blu
forse ne avete sentito parlare è una
città che risente tantissimo della
cultura iraniana la mia interprete nella
2009 nel 2010 nel 2012 si chiamava
suraya moussavi è una delle cose che mi
ha più stupito di su raja e la sua
competenza nel parlare l'inglese perché
mi sono sempre detta la studiato tra una
o ng e l'altra che ha studiato in casa
l'ha studiato da sola quindi non al
caldo delle nostre scuole come potrebbe
capitare a noi
eppure l'ha imparato molto bene
pensate che mentre ero in afghanistan
l'ultima volta che ero in afghanistan
era stato proposto un bellissimo posto
di lavoro in un'organizzazione
internazionale e quindi anche lì ho
pensato che esempio per le sue sorelline
che esempio per le sue cugine che
esempio per le sue amiche una ragazza
che si è fatta completamente da sola una
ragazza alla quale i talebani hanno
ucciso tantissimi membri della tuta
della sua famiglia povera e riuscita
comunque a studiare l'inglese ad essere
per me
tra l'altro con degli episodi divertenti
perché per esempio avete presente il
velo non il velo completo ma quello che
si mette fino a qui che si chiama club e
io stesso avevo la telecamerina avevo il
block notes quindi non l'avevo sempre a
posto e lei con garbo educatissimo
inserendomi nella cultura ovviamente del
del paese mi diceva le donne ti guardano
male
di solito che porta il livello in quel
modo non è proprio una ragazza seria
quindi mi mi raccontava con il suo
inglese perfetto
quello che le altre donne dicevano di me
per me è stata utilissima anche per il
crimine la cultura del paese ma perchè
vi dico questo perché c'è bisogno in
quei paesi di esempi del genere perché
vedete non sono ragazze che possono
andare a scuola in libertà vanno a
scuola
contraddicendo spesso genitori vanno a
scuola contro il volere dei propri di
che la vedono in modo completamente
diverso
vanno a scuola e spesso picchiati o con
ragazzi che tirano loro addosso delle
pietre è un ambiente completamente
diverso dalla nostra che quindi va
compreso va capito e va capita proprio
l'importanza dell'istruzione la grande
chance che abbiamo noi qui in italia ad
avere la possibilità di studiare
comodamente al caldo il terzo esempio
che vi porto invece è il lavoro che mi
ha portato in africa in africa mi sono
occupata soprattutto di
gravidanze precoci e matrimoni precoci
sapete quante sono le ragazze che si
sposano e bambine a livello globale sono
12 milioni l'anno
12 milioni l'anno praticamente come la
popolazione della guinea la popolazione
del ruanda
questo è un dato che mi ha sempre molto
impressionato in team bauer conosciuto
questa ragazza si chiama mouse cvc fan
ba mouth percorreva 11 chilometri per
andare a scuola
11 chilometri per tornare quindi che
cosa faceva stava scuola di più a lungo
possibile perché era molto stanca e
cercava di imparare anche le elezioni
successive alla sua
ecco che ha saltato tantissimi anni
facendo così ed è stata la ragazza più
giovani a entrare all'università di
harare in africa tuttora mantiene questo
primato
ho sempre ammirato la tenacia di questa
ragazza suo inglese perfetto alle sue
movenze la sua sicurezza
quando l'abbiamo portata in italia
contro il volere del fratello e
soprattutto con tante tensioni che si
sono verificate in quel colloquio ci
sono stati anche dei momenti in cui
abbiamo avuto paura
io e la mia collega eravamo nel nord
dello zimbabwe da sola e in questo
villaggio chiedevamo al fratello di
farci portare lei in italia per dare la
testimonianza e lui ci diceva ma io che
cosa ci guadagna dove sono i quattrini e
non gli facevano capire che il futuro di
mouse
era il suo guadagno
parlare e immergersi in queste culture
non è sempre facile però bisogna farlo
con rispetto perché sono culture diverse
dalla nostra
questi tre esempi però testimoniano
soprattutto mouth che sfuggita a un
destino di matrimoni e gravidanze
precoci in africa ho conosciuto bimbe
che hanno avuto questo problema si
chiama fistola ostetrica il tuo uterino
non è pronto a partorire
quindi chi viene questo problema la
fistola ostetrica al punto che poi avrà
delle conseguenze gravi in futuro tra le
quali per esempio il fatto che tu sia in
continente e quindi credetemi
i problemi sono tanti
la morale di quello che io vi dico qual
è la morale è che noi siamo in occidente
gli ultimi per analfabetismo funzionale
invece noi qui abbiamo tutte le
possibilità per istruirci tutte le
possibilità per avere una cultura che ci
permetta come faccio tutti i giorni nel
mio piccolo di partire da numeri da dati
per raccontare realtà corrette e non
travisate quindi io credo che
l'istruzione sia davvero l'arma più
potente che abbiamo per cambiare il
mondo
l'arma per cambiare la nostra vita per
migliorarla
come succede in altre zone del mondo
meno fortunate della nostra sicuramente
dove istruirsi è anche un problema di
possibilità di farlo perché te lo
impediscono
invece potremmo farlo non leggiamo non
studiamo luci istria mio messaggio è
quello di studiare e quello di
[Musica]
provare a cambiare il mondo nel nostro
piccolo leggendo informandoci studiando
sapete io credo che una delle cose più
intelligente che si possa fare e darsi
la possibilità di cambiare idea quando
si sente una persona che è preparata
competente nel sa più di noi quando si
legge un libro in più quando si legge un
articolo di giornale in più quindi
questo è quello che io mi auguro che
l'istruzione torni al centro in questo
paese perché ne ho visti gli effetti in
zone più difficili della nostra in tutto
il mondo e vi assicuro sono risultati
che sono positivi nelson mandela aveva
ragione quando diceva che l'arma più
potente del mondo per cambiarlo il mondo
grazie